welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the many
powerful deities who watch over our
every move and could crush us at any
point in time so you better be burning
your incense and making your offerings
lest you be smite
my name is jessica clemens i'm here
today with off-screen producer
brandon
hey jessica so happy to have you back on
bq so good to see you here we're always
happy to have you here and i am afraid
of all those gods up there i pray to all
of them i hedge my bets you know just
pray to every god that exists and then
that way you're you're number one
i don't think that's how it i mean it
could be how it works
i can tell you right now for this big
question i'm going to be learning a lot
because yeah i think we are i don't know
why yeah what's our big question for
today give it to us brandon
you sound scary oh you should be scared
you should be scared okay because we got
the premiere of moon night coming it's
right around the corner it's gonna
premiere on disney plus any day now and
we're getting ready to be introduced to
a whole new set of deities in the mcu
more gods is there anything more
prolific in the mcu than gods they're
everywhere so many gods
in case you didn't already know the moon
knight series has a lot of close ties to
egyptian mythology you've kind of seen
it in the trailer a little bit if you've
never read the moon night comics it's so
closely tied to egyptian mythology it's
all over the place it's gonna be really
cool but if you're like me and maybe
jessica you might not know a lot about
these gods of egypt maybe you saw that
movie that was wacky and insane i i
wouldn't take that as gospel but we're
we're gonna get into it uh that's yeah
it all leads us to this week's big
question
who are the egyptian gods in marvel
comics huh who are they do you know
these guys jessica uh i know the
scorpion king
he is one of the many gods
he is the uh the least realistic looking
god of all the egyptian gods okay well
to each their own because i played that
video game and nothing looked more
realistic than the scorpion king well
the real-life egyptian gods that we know
from our own real world history have a
counterpart in marvel comics this is
like very similar to how norse mythology
made its way into the comic pages in the
form of the asgardians you know they
take a little bit of the truth they
sprinkle in a little bit of fantasy and
boom boom bada-boom you got yourself a
comic book okay the gods of egypt are
represented in the comics as the
heliopolitans listen there's gonna be a
lot of words i say in this big question
and i'm gonna say i'm wrong uh so don't
add me in the comments at least you own
up to it at least you own up to it i'll
give you that at least you're like hey
look here i'm gonna pronounce a lot of
things wrong and i'm trying jessica and
i are throwing down a blanket apology
right now uh if we insult any of your
deities or your mythologies we really
apologize we're trying our best so we
have uh
the gods of egypt they're they're known
as the heliopolitans or the aeneid okay
so that's like if the norse gods or the
asgardians the egyptian gods are the
unions okay these could be the figures
that we saw in a recent moon knight
featurette you know there was this room
with all these like egyptian iconography
around it and these figures and these
like thrones like these might be the
ania that we're going to get to see uh
on this moonlight series and the word
aeneid actually means a group of nine
and there were nine little throne seats
in that temple so this is very likely
where we can meet all or some of the
immediate wouldn't that be fun huh in
the aeneid are a race of deities that
come from celestial holopolis is it
halapoulos or heliopolis heliopolis
you stan lee
stanley wrote it so you didn't he didn't
have to pronounce it he just wrote it
he's like i'm never to say it out loud
the aeneid are a race of deities that
come from celestial heliopolis which is
a pocket dimension connected to earth
via golden bridge called the path of
gods again this is all very similar to
asgard with the bifrost the rainbow
bridge now the mcu made asgard kind of
this
thing that exists in our universe right
like it's physic it's not in another
dimension necessarily like if you have a
spaceship you can fly to asgard you know
we saw that uh in thor ragnarok right
they went through a little wormhole but
they wound up at asgard so they might do
something similar with the aeneid
uh with the initiate and celestial
helopolis here in the mcu where it could
be like a planet that's out there in
space somewhere or they might go with
this kind of like pocket dimension thing
where it kind of exists in a dimensional
plane in between like earth and you know
another multiverse right does that make
sense jessica am i talking nonsense here
this is the oh i'm waiting for the
editors to like put a bunch of flying
things over my head i need
let's get more into it let's get more
into it and maybe it'll start unraveling
for me i was never good at math okay so
you have the indeed they come from the
celestial heliopolis right now there is
a real world heliopolis that was a major
city in ancient egypt it was named
heliopolis by the greeks which means the
city of the sun uh but you know that's a
very eurocentric way of looking at
things it had a different name when the
ancient egyptians lived there right they
called it inu or onu again i could be
pronouncing this horribly but i'm doing
my best
so you have so heliopolis was a real
ancient city known as inu or onu and it
was the center uh for a religious sect
that worshipped the sun god atom who
later is associated with ra and horus
okay so this was like a real place
that's still there in cairo like there's
a bunch of buildings around there now
probably a pizza hut around the corner
but there's like the ancient ruins of
some of the temples that used to be in
heliopolis so that's really cool that
that this is like a real thing that
they're trying to kind of acknowledge
when they do these comics right
sorry i'm looking it up this is this was
a bad idea putting me on the big
question where i have no information
like i just don't know anything about
this so i'm like oh i'm actually like
listening i have a a notepad next to me
because i'm like writing down the names
you've probably read more moon night
stuff than i have so you'll be helpful
we actually get into some of these gods
okay but keep going sorry so yeah so
heliopolis is like a real place that
existed in egypt it's still there still
there in cairo uh you could go visit it
if you wanted to so check it out if
you're ever in the area but as we look
ahead to the moon night series if you go
to cairo in the show maybe there's a
portal that can take you into the
celestial heliopolis located where the
real heliopolis used to be so the aeneid
have been in marvel comics for a while
they were first mentioned in captain
america comics number 20 from way back
in 1942. cap and bucky are investigating
the murder of a colonel who died in
egypt and who was studying the book of
toth and so they mentioned the in the ed
there but we don't actually see them in
the comics until around 1950 when they
show up in marvel tales number 96. now
moon knight doesn't even appear in the
comics until 1975
uh when he's in werewolf by night and
then he gets his series going in the
1980s uh but these guys were well
established before moon knight even came
around so that's a really cool thing
it's not like they had to go back and
retcon all of this stuff into marvel
history it was already there jessica
let's go through some of the guides we
think could likely make an appearance in
the moonlight series and how they fit in
marvel and real world history uh won't
that be a lot of fun huh wouldn't that
be a lot of fun
i have my i ha i'm ready i'm i'm ready
i'm ready you're ready
i'm ready i love god
i love god i love all the gods please
don't smite me i love god
i pray to each and every one of you as
brandon said earlier and you know what
and you know what i'm praying for you
down there too buddy don't worry about
it oh we're all
mephisto
we don't say that here we don't say that
here he who shall not be named satan's
not such a bad guy he gets a really bad
rap but i think it's uh
if you go back to the old text you know
he's just an angel who fell he had some
questions i think it's fair to have some
questions nah dude i only got kicked out
go on
continue
okay so let's start with the most
obvious of the indian who's definitely
going to show up at moon knight kanshu
okay he's the one we know about he's
that bird skull looking [ __ ]
who's come to has come to mess stuff up
right
we definitely know that kanchu's going
to be in moon knight uh as he is the
patron god of moon knight right he's the
one who gives moon knight his powers in
the comics konchu started out as like a
rather benevolent god in the initial run
of moon knight back in the 1980s more
recently he's been seen as more of an
antagonistic figure to mark spectre
right konchu is of course based on the
real egyptian lunar god khan soo there's
no h i don't know if you pronounce it
the same but there's no h in the
egyptian version of konchu kanchu
kanchu was related
in egyptian mythology to travel and the
passage of time because he was related
to the moon you know as we see like the
sun as a god that's brought across the
sky the moon is a god that's brought
across the sky
and that you know obviously the moon
going across the sky it's time that's
the passage of time and kanchu in uh
egyptian mythology was also important to
the creation of new life and all living
creatures so very important god i love
the definition you gave him that
bird-looking mother
it sounds like you're ready to fight him
and to be honest not not going back to
the 80s one but going back to all of the
new versions of moon knight you would
want to fight him he is a monster he's
not a good guy or at least his motives
aren't yeah yeah they're certainly
making out in the trailer to be like
he's going to be he's scary
midnight's scared of him or at least
even scared of him i don't know how mark
feels about him so another god that
might show up on the series uh is anubis
some theories out there actually think
that ethan hawke's character could turn
out to be anubis in this series spoiler
alert if that's to be true wouldn't that
be kind of cool wouldn't that be kind of
cool
who said that
i just said it i just said it and i
typed it on there oh so you're saying it
so i will fight you on it yeah yeah okay
i knew it i knew it
they suggested i follow it on twitter
and i said this guy's insane i said i
received them this is brandon's burner
right here you think he's gonna play
anubis i think it would be very cool if
ethan hawke's character who seems to be
leading this cult maybe a death cult
turns out to be the god anubis uh and
that's why kanchu's trying to get mark
spector to fight him uh because you know
he doesn't want anubis stepping on his
turf or whatever
interesting okay well and a new anubis
has some very some very interesting
motives that we're gonna get into uh as
we keep going through some of these
guides um you know anubis in marvel
comics is of course based on the
egyptian mythology of anubis same
spelling and anubis is that
jackal-headed god who is the god of
death and rebirth along with funerals
mummification and the afterlife anubis
is the one that meets souls right as
they die to judge their worthiness to
enter the underworld um and in the
comics mark spectre meets anubis when
he's mortally wounded so there
definitely could be a way to introduce
anubis in this show if it turns out that
ethan hawk's not anubis if they show us
a scene where like mark spector you know
he's in a war somewhere and he dies he
could meet anubis and that leads to him
meeting kanchu and getting the powers as
i teased jessica anubis actually has
some interesting interactions with some
of the other gods we're going to mention
so we're going to circle back to that in
a second okay but do you think we might
see anubis in this since he's had
absolutely a prominent role in the
comics absolutely and if we i i would
hope we see him
a lot but if we didn't see and or see
anubis if we didn't see anubis a lot i
hope that we'd see anubis within one of
uh mark's
mark or
jake or whoever any of us
yeah any of them i hope he's following
like a storyline to one of the
characters yeah uh anubis is probably my
favorite part and i don't know i just
think from seeing the trailers anubis is
going to look so cool coming out so like
take advantage of that take advantage of
having a walking anubis walking around
in a in like where in london wherever
they are yeah right
and it was just so cool when i was a
young man a very pivotal film came out
called stargate which blew my mind oh uh
it was so awesome pre-series like this
is the one that started it all and one
of the coolest things we're seeing these
humans with these metallic heads that
represented horus and anubis and ron it
was like so cool uh so yeah i even you
know just seeing kancho in the trailers
i'm so excited to see like countries
oh yeah we're all gonna have nightmares
in the
do we think those scenes of konshu
like the bert it's gonna be like a bird
person
is bird it's bird person from or bird
whatever from rick and morty do you
think
[Laughter]
[Music]
they bring a lot of adult swim writers
to do a bunch of marvel movies already
well most of the people from rick and
morty's writers are all doing like nerd
things might as well just put dan harmon
in
moonlight that's his debut for the nerd
world well
f murray abraham is playing koncho i
believe in the series but it would be
nice to have a nod to bird person that
would be really great jessica let's talk
about the big dog at the top of this
immediate pyramid ra
or atom or amundra he's got a bunch of
names uh but he's based on the actual
egyptian god also known as raw atom etc
etc etc again this is another straight
transfer from the real egyptian gods so
uh ra is the god of the sun but he's
also known as the king of the gods so
let's think of raw as someone who's like
odin to the asgardians maybe he's even
more like bore because he's like the
original god of the amids okay ra was an
elder god and the son of gaia
and he was the progenator of all the
immunes so you go way way way way back
in marvel history there's very there's
like nothingness right and then there's
somethingness
and there's all these kind of elder
spirits and gods that are protecting
things and destroying evil and blah blah
blah blah and so there's all these
demons on earth and the uh the elder
goddess gaia has a son named ra and he's
the one who's supposed to go down to
earth and like kill all the demons and
stuff he does that good job brah now you
get to make your own gods and so he
becomes the daddy of all the aneed and
this is kind of similar to egyptian
mythology in that ra was the father of
all the other gods so he's the top he's
he's the big daddy okay but one thing
about him that's very interesting he's
pretty much unable to enter the earthly
realm maybe because he's so powerful or
so ancient he can't really come down to
earth so he always has to find like an
avatar or a champion to represent him on
our plane so i don't know if we'll ever
if we'll see like the true
ra in this show right but he might have
someone represent him or it might be
cool if like it's a jumping spirit like
all these random people keep coming up
to mark spectre and they're like i'm
wrong no no i'm wrong now no i'm wrong
you know just keep like i'm i'm coming
to deliver messages or something like
that
i don't think they're going to see them
because if we want to make a second
season that's when we need to see them
because they're such a big part i think
they're going to be mentioned a lot like
oh
he's coming or something like there's
going to be always like
big bad's coming like it's coming but
like i don't think we're gonna see him
in the first yeah like i said maybe we
won't see the actual god but just it's
representative right just random
strangers being the avatar of ra and you
know we mentioned that kind of quick
shot we get of that throne room looking
thing in the trailer and not all nine of
the seats are full there only seems to
be like a couple figures in there
there's a bunch of statues but there's
not it's not like every throne has like
god in it so yeah maybe we won't see rod
they'll just be like ah raw's around
he's busy he's doing his raw stuff
raw's doing their [ __ ] and also
if we do see someone
as raw they could be only there to like
try killing mark or also just trying to
like ruin things yeah so it's it's going
to be a small short appearance i think
another interesting god to see on this
series would be osiris now osiris
doesn't have a ton of interaction with
moon knight in the comics but he would
be really cool to see on this series
he's based on the egyptian god osiris
who was the god of fertility agriculture
the afterlife the dead resurrection life
and vegetation a lot of things basically
that could be some of the confusing
stuff about egyptian mythology sometimes
these gods
kind of cover similar things based on
the region that was worshiping them uh
they kind of get moved around a lot but
um what's most interesting about osiris
as it relates to marvel comics
is that he is the father of anubis who
we mentioned earlier you see osiris was
caught knocking boots with nephes who
was the wife of seth at the time
so seth we love god drama god drama is
the best drama this is some real god
drama right here okay so seth is like
another old school god uh who was
brother who was osiris's younger brother
uh and was one of like the ancient
aeneid gods right uh and so osiris kind
of knocks up with his wife and they have
anubis as an offspring osiris also had a
wife at the time named isis
it's a whole thing but um
uh in real egyptian mythology uh seth
who's also known as set without the h um
he was really pissed about this and he
chop he kills osiris and chops him up
into 14 pieces uh and that his wife isis
has to put him back together in marvel
comics similar things happen there's
this affair anubis is born instead of
chopping him up seth walks osiris horus
and isis up in a temple a pyramid in
egypt and they're later freed by odin
some crazy stuff jessica a lot of drama
a lot of like
you know uh romantic relationships
between gods um i don't know if they
want to get into all of this in
moonlight but i think it would be
interesting if we see osiris mainly
because it's the father of anubis so if
anubis is showing up causing all this
drama conscious trying to fight him all
the stuff's going on maybe his dad shows
up osiris and it's like what the hell's
going on here
what do you do with the news you're
making me look bad you're the family
looking yeah you're making me look bad
maybe turn off the tv come down here for
this yeah come down to earth hate this
place trashy dirty anubis is like you
don't know what you're talking about dad
you you had an affair you're sleeping
around uh i'm i i'm a bastard you know i
i i'm the product of
an affair this is messed up what do you
expect from me dad and just meanwhile
yeah
just like what is going on i can't deal
with all this i'm the product of an
affair you did this you you did this you
did this to me
i'd be like okay cool i love this drama
um i
still i feel like it'd be adding too
much if we threw him in there this is
just story line me putting in my two
cents uh i think it'd be too much
putting them in there but i love that
drama and i feel like that drama still
won't
well maybe they won't approach it in the
series that's the problem like i feel
like it's really fun in the comics but
maybe they just won't even address it in
the series yeah it might be a bit of a
stretch i know i'm really stretching
here on this one but i just like it
because osiris doesn't have a ton in the
comics and like i said it doesn't have a
ton with moon knight and if they really
want to subvert the expectations of the
audience who might be reading up on moon
night they could be like well here's a
guide you didn't even see coming okay
and he's pissed that is
justice they could give this uh they
could give osiris a better
not a better um more of a storyline more
of an arc
so that way it's more important to refer
back to them
i just don't know how likely it would be
to see them with anubis but i do like
the god nonetheless
love the god don't know
him
i've got a good one for you here i got a
really good one okay come on now what
would be really really cool to see show
up at moon night would be the inclusion
of best okay okay
best
best now if you're out there thinking
i've heard that name before it's because
you have
bast has already been referenced in the
black panther film she was the goddess
in wakandan legend who first showed
bashenga where to find the heart-shaped
herb if you remember that little story
we get at the beginning of the black
panther film where they talk about the
origins of wakanda and the heart-shaped
herb and the vibranium uh that all
relates to bats fast is like the main
god
or goddess that the wakandans worship
and because it's all taking place in
africa you know you have egypt you have
a wakanda all of these gods are
connected so i think it'd be really cool
to see bass show up since it's already
part so much a part of like wakanda and
the black panther storyline it would be
really cool to see bass show up in that
room uh talk to mark spector and kind of
like really tie these series together
but it's it's really important to
remember that in the comics bass has a
very vast history with the aeneid bas is
of course based on the egyptian goddess
bastet who was a warrior goddess and
protector of raw and often depicted with
a lion or panther head hence why she
makes so much sense as the main goddess
for black panther in marvel comics bass
is one of the oldest of the aeneid and a
direct child of ra so if you think of
this like family tree we've kind of
created here you have rod at the top raw
has kids like set osiris uh and of
course best i mentioned earlier how
anubis played a large role with some of
these gods and their storylines and now
that we know some of these players and
i've kind of laid them out i could share
my the very interesting connection that
i found in marvel comics at one point in
the past anubis tried to steal the
throne of the celestial heliopolis from
ra and to accomplish this he wanted to
cut out raw's heart and absorb his power
okay so this is very similar to the
asgardians again remember loki wanted to
kill odin take over the throne and all
that he felt like he had a place there
here we have it again okay uh we have
raw we have his grandson anubis who's a
bastard who's born out of wedlock right
who's born of an affair he wants to take
over the celestial heliopolis and to do
this he's going to cut out raw's heart
and absorb his power but raz is a smart
guy okay he's been around the block he's
an elder god he's not going to let this
happen so he goes to his daughter who he
trusts the most one of his eldest
daughters best and he takes his heart
out and he gives it to bass for safe
keeping and what does bass do with his
heart well jessica no she eats it
no no she's nicer than that she hides
the heart in the center of africa and
what does that heart do oh
it creates the heart-shaped herb jessica
which gives
us black panther their powers okay
oh
so i know this is a moonlight series
okay this is a moon night series right
and we don't have a lot of time it's a
limited series but man if they get into
the this heart-shaped herb stuff a
little bit it would be so
cool to lay all this out call them call
them up now okay first off you either
need to call up disney right now or they
already know about this and they're
already putting in the steps board they
they just they just want any cross any
kind of like we can put these two
superheroes into the same world so badly
that this is written already for them
like from the next black panther they
can talk about more of a more about the
herb's history than just what they know
so i this
and then we'll be like oh moon knight oh
yeah and that's what i love about this
that is amazing yeah yeah that's what i
love about the asgardians right they use
a lot of our mythology to tell those
stories that's what i wanted to do here
with the aeneid like use these real
egyptian mythologies to help fuel these
stories uh and make it kind of that kind
of real history you know that that kind
of real fictional history of our own
world uh it would be really cool and if
you had this explanation of where the
heart-shaped herb comes from they could
just kind of sprinkle that in in this
moon night series that would be so cool
um if you also remember that's so sick
it's that isn't that so when i found
that i was like holy holy crap it all
ties together that's so sick yeah i'm so
sick
i could see on this moon night series
how like anubis is pissed off maybe he's
trying to get to the heart-shaped or to
get that power to take over
uh like he wanted to do originally uh
and it's up to moon knight to stop him
like that would be really really cool if
you also remember uh in the mcu film uh
civil war t'challa tells us when he's
talking about how his his dad dies that
bast and sekhmet are the gods that bring
the souls to the ancestral plane that
the wakandans believe in right and of
course they believe in it because we saw
it it's real checkmate
sekhmet is a is another god who exists
in egyptian mythology she's a warrior
goddess and she's sometimes depicted as
a lioness so you have bass and sekhmet
they both have cat heads whether they be
lions or panthers or just a pretty
little kitty real goddess is an egyptian
mythology and they also exist within
marvel comics and they are aeneid so
they're probably idiots so yeah i think
we could definitely see some of these in
moonlight you know we're definitely
going to see kanchu i'm 99 sure we're
going to see anubis i think anubis is
definitely going to show up i thought
anubis was in the trailer but maybe i
think you can kind of see like already
so fast right see something that looks
that's what i thought it was a new
business sometimes when you're watching
these trailers you're like oh i've read
the comic i know this is the person and
then it's not at all and you're just
lying to yourself so that could be me i
oh god after that bass i know don't you
want to see bass so bad i i wanna just
mention it just mention it right mention
it so we know that it's gonna come up
again right like just bring it up once
so we know we're gonna get that story
that is so cool you know in that throne
room that we see we see those nine
thrones which i think represent the
indian and i really think bass should be
one of the the gods that they introduced
on this show a woman in a red dress i
mean what if that's bass or sekhmet you
know that he's actually talking to could
be really cool i'm very excited for the
show and to see all the cool egyptian
mythology they bring into it if you
haven't looked into egyptian mythology
look into it it's crazy it's sexy as
hell
your destiny
it's sexy i mean all those all those
mythologies whether it's greek or norse
or egyptian they have all these weird
relationships that all the gods and
goddesses get into and all these
offspring that they have and they eat
their children or they cut people up or
they do all this crazy they swallow
their kids they break their head open
the kid jumps out they yeah turn into an
eagle and go into the sun get too close
icarus there's just so much there's so
much like there's so much that's going
on uh in these storylines i mean a lot
of times they're [ __ ] with us humans
right they're messing with us but man
they with each other a lot they are
too much the thing is when you with a
god a god with another god is just like
why would you do that because they'll
just smite you like they'll just mite
the people like someone's like oh i
harvest grain and then zeus is gonna be
like hey i'm gonna just throw a
lightning bolt on it because you pissed
me off
i'm gonna throw a lightning bolt at you
i'm also gonna have sex with your wife
uh and then i'm gonna get out of here
i'm gonna turn around real quick and
bang your wife and sorry oh my god what
are you gonna do about it stuff stuff
stuff
if you haven't already grabbed one of
the limited edition latest obsession
shirts inspired by the batman over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
your time is running out okay those
shirts are going to disappear into the
shadows just like our favorite caped
crusader they're going to walk slowly
backwards into the dark you know what i
mean so yeah head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com uh pick up one of
those latest obsession shirts before
they're gone forever and before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help us bring
the question to you 72 percent of
americans report being tired every day i
know i am but when was the last time any
of us took a nap a power nap helps you
reset your body and brain to unlock the
energy you need if you want to empower
your power nap let najitsu help
napjitsu's natural supplements were made
by people who know how it feels to be
tired and busy their patent-pending
formulas have natural ingredients like b
vitamins guarana and ginseng to give you
a boost of energy without the crash
later each nabjitsu product provides
brain boosting nootropics to unlock
steady energy right when you need it the
result your peak performance all day
long nap jitsu supplements are packaged
into small packets so you can take them
whenever and wherever you might need an
energy boost whether you need to
experience deeper sleep or unlock
immediate lasting energy each napjitsu
product is designed to help you achieve
your optimal performance remember the
smart rest more the wise rest better
rest up and level up with napjitsu for a
limited time receive 30 off your first
snap jitsu when you go to notjutsu.com
bigquestion go to napjitsu.com
bigquestion for 30 off your first
purchase today that's
question napjitsu.com mission is simple
make the most comfortable clothes ever
and watch every item sold with an equal
item donated so when you buy bomb bus
you also are given to someone in need
that's great bomb has designed their
socks shirts and underwear to be clothes
you can't wait to put on every day
everything they make is soft seamless
tagless and has a luxuriously cozy feel
they're made from super soft materials
like merino wool pima cotton and even
cashmere which makes them the perfect
cozy layers there's a pair of bomba
socks for everything you do they come in
tons of options like comfy performance
style for every sport and activity that
keeps you moving bomba's t-shirts are
made with thoughtful design features
like invisible seams soft fabrics and
the perfect weight so they hang just
right bomba's underwear has a barely
there feel with second skin support that
might make you forget they're even there
in a good way
you ever like that feeling when you're
going commando this is these are the
underwear for you
and did you know that socks underwear
and t-shirts are the three most
requested clothing items at homeless
shelters that's why bombus donates one
of every item you buy go to bombus.com
big question and get 20 off your first
purchase that's b o m
b a s dot com slash big question for
twenty percent off bombas dot com slash
big question jessica are you ready for
the bite size question today yes baby
and get ready for a little tasty morsel
of a question
here you go this is from stout trout 83
on twitter stout trout wants to know
does hulk need oxygens to survive that's
an interesting question
how do you kill a hulk well in evil hank
pym showed us the most grotesque way to
do it is the blow that big green sucker
up from the inside out if you remember
that what if emphasized
he knew how to get that sucker dead he
said i'm going inside and i'm blowing
that [ __ ] up but is there another way
you could do it could you perhaps
deprive the less than jolly green giant
of oxygen to wipe it out this is a very
important question because it seems like
he wouldn't and as it turns out maybe
not often when the hulk was in
environments without oxygen it would be
explained that he could survive by
holding his breath for a really long
time there have been numerous instances
in the comics where the hulk has
survived the vacuum of space or being
submerged underwater and is either
talking or making it clear that he's not
holding his breath as time went on the
hulk became a being that would not only
survive but adapt because the hulk is so
hell-bent on living and dying really
pisses him off more than anything his
body will often find ways to adapt to
any situation to keep him alive in hulk
number 77 from 2005 he battles a giant
squid underwater and doesn't drown from
a lack of oxygen which
[Music]
is insane he comes to the conclusion
that his body developed a gland that
produced an oxygenated fluorocarbon
emulsion to keep him alive he's like a
liquid cooled
that's
computer
which
was like ever defined as a hulk did you
ever see the abyss
jessica that uh
the james cameron movie the abyss
there's this great scene and this was
like a real thing
there's a liquid that they uh some
scientists developed that you could
breathe it basically if you let it fill
your lungs it was oxygenated enough that
you could still breathe okay so yeah
like you said like those computers that
are liquid cooled you know you just like
stick them all in water and it still
runs that's basically the inside of the
hulk right so he's underwater fighting
the squid and he has his body develops a
gland that just like makes this liquid
really fast so that he can just breathe
underwater basically but he has to stay
as the hulk if he ever was just like
yeah yeah oh this water's so cool and
i'm going to turn back into
like it's not going oh i'm so relaxed
now i'm breathing underwater
what if you were sipping margaritas on a
sun-drenched beach turning brown instead
of green i would be it's cool it's nice
the whole the whole slot like i'll turn
back into banner when he's underwater
right because then he would die so he's
like i gotta stay home that's true i
would hope not but if he's too relaxing
we'll get into it
we'll get into the debate
now can bruce banner survive underwater
now there have been instances in the
comics where it seems like the hulk does
need oxygen there have been instances
throughout hulk's run where a lack of
oxygen would cause hulk to pass out and
turn back into banner this was likely
done more of a plot or the story than
definitively saying that the hulk is
susceptible to oxygen deprivation which
makes complete sense because they
probably just didn't want to justify
that yeah
yeah i mean you read a lot of comics
jessica you know like every now and then
like the writer will like change the
powers of like a character for a
storyline you know
so it's like like you said throughout
the comics there's been times where they
basically deprived the hulk of oxygen
and he passes out and turns back into
banner but most of the time the way hulk
is now especially he's like so op right
he's so powerful you can't just deprive
him of oxygen because he's just like
survives through it because that's like
the whole 100 percent you can't stop it
and like
you know that's something in that i know
people complain about in the mcu where
it's like oh they've really nerfed the
hulk he's not as strong as he should be
you kind of have to do that sometimes
right he can't just be like an
unkillable machine like you have to find
ways to weaken him every now and then
[Music]
for the purposes of the story yeah it's
kind of crazy that the hulk just
survives like you can't you keep
when you try and kill him it just makes
him stronger yeah i'm a bad [ __ ] you
can't kill me it just makes the hulk
seem like he's indestructible and he is
not so it's like we need to remember and
stay grounded in the comic book world
that like
he can still die he can still die yeah
you want him to have weaknesses it makes
him more relatable yes
yeah you need them to have weaknesses
we've talked about it before a big
question there's like that comic where
like the hulk lives till like the end of
time and there's radioactive bugs oh yes
his flesh just grows back it's like
that's not a fun movie i don't even see
that movie so this box of scraps if you
were a god brandon wait wait you gotta
really enjoy it give it i'm doing it no
no
oh you want me to do the
scraps be like are you ready for the box
scraps
are you ready for the box of scraps
[Music]
ah god brandon if you will imagine if
you were a god
what would you be the god of um
and um
be realistic
and
think about it really this is a serious
question
okay okay okay well i always like
admired those gods that were like you
know like dionysus like they got a wine
and parties and good times just a party
you just want a party no no i'll go a
little deeper than that i'll go a little
deeper than that okay uh i would be the
god of bringing snacks to a late night
party you know what i mean you're at a
party you've been having a good time and
then all sudden someone shows up at the
door and they're they they're a little
late but they roll in with that box of
like 20 tacos and they're like this is
for the party and they'd be like oh
praise brandon the god of late night
snacks he has provided once again like
that would be what i would be the god of
people would pray to me that i would
show up late at night providing snacks
for their get-togethers their shindigs
their fun times that's what i would be
and like a god and like a god you'll
have you'll have followers and you'll
have people that criticize you and i
would be that one that criticized you
because i'd be like i'm tired of
branding bringing the damn taco bell for
10 deal i want some chicken nuggets i'd
be irritated i have another specific
taste it's not just tacos whatever you
want provided oh so it's like a buffet
of snacks so is it just a dinner it's
almost like an ambrosia it's like a hook
scenario jessica like whatever you
imagine yourself eating it becomes real
okay so if you want chicken nuggets you
get chicken nuggets if if you want donor
kebabs boom you get donut kebabs so you
just want french fries with mayonnaise
and malt vinegar that's what you get
okay that's what i'm gonna provide
malt liquor now if you don't believe in
me and you're and you're smited by me
what i bring is terrible like i just
bring raisins or i bring like
tuna salad
i love a tuna salad so
go off go off and punish me if you want
um
i'm gonna i would love to be the goddess
of death um
if i was a god i'd want to be the
goddess of death but let's be realistic
i'd probably just be hermes um and
just be delivering mail uh let's be
honest with ourselves i don't have what
it takes to be the guy you gotta believe
in yourself jessica you could be the
goddess of death that's the first reason
why i would be hermes
because i have no confidence i'd be like
oh you know what i'll just get i'll be
the fedex i'll i'll sprint over here
real quick oh i'll be like can you sign
for this zeus no okay i'll return it
people hate me but i would want to be
hella for sure oh why wouldn't i want to
be her i want to be healthy because get
out of here it seems like a lot of work
but hella makes it look fun
and that's what i like i love a villain
i would want to be a villain but i don't
think i have the
capability to like kill my loved ones
so i don't think i could be yellow i
think we could get you there jessica i
think we could get you here i don't know
i love too many people that's why i'm
hermes i'm willing to do too much for
the people i love oh you guys get in the
comments and tell us what god you would
want to be um whether it's the goddess
of death uh the goddess of delivering
packages uh or even the god of snacks as
uh brandon said basically if you want to
be a a cracker barrel
that's what brandon just said
i'm like i'm the god of cracker barrel
oh please get that guy third example or
any day of the week uncle hershey's
uncle rehearsals breakfast boom here it
is boom i brought you a biscuit bigger
than your head
you guys that was the big question that
was the box of scraps that was
everything that me and brandon could
give you possibly today um thank you
brandon for joining me or actually
letting me join you on this very shared
equipment ambitious endeavor
we shared it and we shared it but like i
learned i'm the one taking away
everything taking away all the knowledge
so thank you brandon thank you me thank
you um new rockstars you can follow
brandon at grin and barrack you can
follow me at lulu underscore clemens
follow me rockstars at new rockstars
here on youtube and all social media
platforms and make sure to hit that
notification bell like subscribe comment
and if you want to continue the
conversation on our new rockstars
discord server is now open to the public
if you're over 18.
you
click the link for the new rockstars
discord server in the description below
bye bye folks
[Music]
you